if you could function is a function
right and it looks roughly like this 3x
plus 1 it's got a gradient of 3 so it's
pretty steep and it's hitting the y axis
at once I'm guessing something like this
ok there you go that's what the line
looks like I can find the inverse
function of this the function that's
like the opposite the flip side of this
by taking my inputs and swapping them
with my outputs ok so what I very
briefly showed you was well what happens
if we do that ok I would say x equals 3
y plus 1 that is the inverse function ok
then none of that is the inverse now
it's a little bit weird to write our
equations with X as the subject we have
been doing that ever for years so we
said well let's just still bit algebra
on this and make Y the subject because
that's kind of what we're used to but
this is almost exactly the example we
did so let's just or it is the example
dude so let's just quickly rehearsin how
do I make why this subject in this case
can someone give me just a first step
yeah that's up let's get this one and
let's get him over the other side I will
subtract 1 from both sides okay so that
gives me this on this line ok and then I
only have to do one more thing to get Y
by itself rather than 3 1 what do I do
yeah I'm going to divide both sides by 3
ok so that gives me X minus 1 over 3
equals y and I'll just appear out of it
so you can see I get this so here's my
inverse function okay now very very
quickly even though I think this is fine
this is nice and neat it's in my
interest to write this it's a straight
line more like this you see how I've got
my MX plus B form so I can read the
gradient straight away and I can read
its y-intercept straight away okay so
let me just quickly rewrite this in this
way if I separate out these terms do you
agree like X is being divided by 3
right I've got X and there's an over
three and then what's left over well
there's a minus one also divided by
three okay so these lines are the same
I've just taken one fraction and I'm
working at a pot and now I know he's my
gradient and he is my intercept I can
draw this thing so on let's see here I
fed it like a gentle gentle ingredients
well it's not very steep at all so it's
gonna do something like this okay no yes
you bet he's our inverse function now
what I want to do is borrow this
function notation we've been working on
and use that because at the moment I'm
kind of confused like I've got like was
this and y equals that like which one is
it really okay and so I can use function
notation where F is a name or G's enable
that kind of thing and use it to my
advantage
okay so let's rewrite this exact example
I'm going to say I'm just continuing
from that if rather than calling it Y if
I call it f of X is 3x plus 1 okay and
what I'm going to do is I'm going to
name the inverse of F as f with a
negative 1 up there okay now please
Marcus okay and admittedly it's a bit
confusing to start with right um this is
not f to the power of minus 1 even
though that's exactly how I've written
it okay what I read that as has is as f
inverse in exactly the same way but on
your calculator
you've got up there on your calculator
you have above upside cause and tail
right about sign currently you see you
see sign and then there's a minus 1
there now that is not signed to the
power of minus 1
it doesn't do it's not this division
thing okay in fact we read that as sine
inverse and cos inverse and tan inverse
and I read this as f inverse now I've
already found it it is right there so
this is right now
it's X - is that okay
now the great advantage of using this
function notation in this way and I just
I just label that so in your notes when
you come back to this later you'll be
like what's that referring to right so
this is a function and this is inverse
of that function
the great advantage here is twofold
number one I don't get my y's mixed up
like I've got y equals this and why cuz
this will just make up your mind which
one's Y just tell me which one you want
here they've actually got two different
names so I want oh it mix them up with
each other
okay so that's good but secondly I can
demonstrate really clearly why the
inverse is what it is by using this
function notation business and
evaluating okay here's how I'm going to
show you each if I take a value pick
another between one and ten five okay
five one it's just like that's right now
if I say if I say five okay I'm your F
of five now what does this mean I'm
taking five as an example of an input
stick it in and I should get it out put
out that makes sense let's just quickly
evaluate it because you've been doing
this all morning right F of five I'm
gonna take everywhere I see an X is
gonna be one of them and I'm gonna
replace it with a five UK with that
three times five plus one that's 16 so
far so good now the inverse function
what it does is it switches everything
around right like that's literally what
I did I took the X's otherwise and I
flipped them right I swapped places
so therefore what this means is instead
of taking our input and giving you an
output it's gonna do exactly the first
watch right if I say F the inverse and I
take what was the output which you just
told me it was okay I should be able to
get back to the input if I've done the
function quickly let's give it a go okay
here we go
this is my um inverse function right so
I'm just going to dutifully replace
every X I see with the number 16 okay
so I'm gonna put a 16-man is it though
yeah let's um let's let's crush this sir
sixteen over three and this is minus one
over three so they have the same
denominator already it's kind of hate me
so I'm just gonna put that as minus one
right that's not minus 1/3 okay sixteen
take away one of course is 15 it's fine
do you see it what right in the first
place
you gave me an input and I gave you an
app work right but the inverse function
takes that process and it goes backwards
okay it goes backwards it says well you
know if you give me the output I should
be able to tell you where you came from
your input right and that's the way
functions work I should be able to go in
one direction or the other because I'll
always have one